salut je m'appelle fabien olicard dans
ce format que nous abordons un point en
particulier du cerveau dans les épisodes
précédents vous avez proposé dans la
section commentaires que l'on parle de
l'influencé des couleurs sur nous c'est
le sujet du jour bienvenue dans matière
grise
[Musique]
dans cet épisode vous allez vivre quatre
expériences expérience une réception des
couleurs expérience deux négatifs
expérience 3 c'est à vous expérience 4
émotions coloré le tout avec la présence
très appréciée de maths
[Musique]
la perception des couleurs et très
personnel très intime rien ne nous
permettra jamais de savoir si ce que
j'appelle moi le bleu est véritablement
de la même couleur dans votre esprit
pour vous une perception c'est forcément
intime ce que l'on sait par contre c'est
que les couleurs ont un impact direct
sur notre cerveau certaines personnes
les synesthètes pense même en couleur
mais avant de vous en reparler nous
allons analyser votre réception des
couleurs en 1917 shinobu ishihara a créé
un test de perception des couleurs c'est
actuellement le plus utilisé pour
déceler un symptôme de daltonisme chez
un patient par exemple le test est très
fiable sans pour autant connaître le
degré de daltonisme et les composés de
38 planches de couleurs différentes les
anomalies principal du daltonisme sont
de 2 tera nope où la personne ne
distingue pas le vert le pro tannock où
la personne ne voit pas le rouge et le
tri tan up qu'un petit peu plus rares ou
la personne ne voit ni levèrent ninja
chermat cher fabien parlons de la
réception des couleurs dans un premier
temps à vous les recevez bien oui on
veut c'est une bonne nouvelle expérience
de
sessad ans mais il faut que j'y aille en
a maintenant cinq minutes est-ce que tu
connais shibo nous du tout alors shibo
nous c'est un gars qui a créé le test
que nous allons voir maintenant d'accord
on l'a appelée et c'est assez marrant tu
me diras le test de chiboub d'accord je
m'y attendais pas souvent les chercheurs
ils font ça pour qu'on se souvienne
d'eux évidemment en gros ce sont des
pastilles colorées à l'intérieur
desquels se trouvent des nombres des
chiffres quel est le chiffre que tu vois
ici si tenté que tu envoies
dire à la française 97
dans cete 97 et voilà comment ce parfait
on les enchaîne comme ce 45 45 c'est pas
mal 57 d'accord vous les voyez vous
aussi sur votre écran actuellement 90 6
non c'était 96 c'est le soir 35 16 h à
eu un temps un tout petit peu plus long
sur la whey silva 29 oui 5 t sur moi oui
c'est ça
6-8 hockey 12 oui 15 battu voix sur la
même configuration
daru dans cet état 5c tel quel
c'est sur la même configuration de
couleur ou alors 15 et 16 sont des
nombres que tu maîtrises pas énormément
tu comptes de quatre ans était possible
ou alors c'est cette configuration de
couleurs qui est plus dur pour en tout
cas la bonne nouvelle c'est que tu n'as
aucun problème de perception de couleur
est tu n'as aucun daltonisme yes par
contre peut-être qu'il y en a certains
ou certaines d'entre vous qui ont eu des
difficultés je vous en parle juste après
dans ces cas là parce qu'il ya plusieurs
types de daltonisme et c'est le meilleur
test qui existent pour voir comment
fonctionne la perception des couleurs et
pour toutes les autres expériences qu'on
va faire ensuite c'était intéressant de
commencer par ce test on va maintenant
passer aux tests des bandes ah ok alors
je vais te faire voir un test de bande à
se sont énormément de bande colorée
ouais je vais te demander de me dire
combien tu vois deux bandes de nuances
de couleurs différentes ne te fie pas
aux traits d'impression ouais c'est
assez l'imprimante qui a bavé un petit
peu je sais exactement le nombre de
banques qui a donc tu pourras pas
m'avoir ok d'accord après un indice ces
deux couleurs sont vraiment différentes
d'accord ça c'est ce que je me demandais
je te laisse au quasi parfait le but
c'est de le faire sincèrement évidemment
on va voir comment fonctionne t comme
des cônes qui réceptionne la couleur
d'accord mais on est d'accord les yeux
on est d'accord que la bande elle a même
dû du déroule sur wii a pas de dégrader
il n'y a pas d'argent piège bon à
l'inter ces [ __ ] aller
[Musique]
ok bonjour en santé mathieu à 50 50 50
50 bande après je pense que je
t'explique comment j'ai compté
brièvement sur certains certains
certains éléments bon il ya des gradés
donc je comptais le début et la fin
comme étant une couleur différente mais
bon c'est un possible deuxième
impression peut-être que certains
dégradé correspondait au début de la
bande suivante enfin bref mais il ya
cinq ans autre fois où je me suis dit ah
ça a changé de couleur je t'avoue que
l'impression m'arrange pas moi non plus
lp dégueulasse par contre à 50 ça veut
dire que tu a aucun souci de caunes non
plus à ascq est pas le cas de toute la
population surtout chez les hommes on a
tendance à voir moins de nuances de
couleurs que les femmes par exemple pour
que ce qu'on y prête aussi clairement
mon nom c'est bien pour se nommer mais
cfc plus développée chez elle donc tu
allais quatre types de cônes qui on
appelle ça déconne tetra chromatique
c'est seulement 25% de la population
d'accord est en général ce sont des
personnes qui n'aiment pas la couleur
jaune parce qu'elle leur serve de
manière plus agressive quel est ton
rapport au jaune assez cordiale non
écoute c'est une couleur que tu portes
ou que tu m'aides un an non c'est vrai
que très peu
tu vois céder quand je dis n'aime pas le
jeûne n'est pas en mode non
mais c'est spontanément c'est une
couleur sur laquelle ces personnes là ne
vont pas voter que ce serait intéressant
de savoir dans les commentaires si ça le
fait pour vous aussi ceux qui en ont
compté un peu moins que matt on va dire
jusqu'à 10 15 me de moins vous avez que
trois types de cônes donc c'est une
vision tri chromatique et c'est 50 % des
gens c'est mon cas bah oui oui oui c'est
à dire que moi j'ai l'impression de voir
des bandes qui se répète à plusieurs
endroits tu vois ok alors qu'en fait pas
nécessairement mais je déclare je suis
en dessous de toi là dessus et ceux qui
ont compté moins de 20 vous avez une
vision dit chromate c'est à dire comme
les chiens oui un communiqué ba et c'est
vous avez deux types de cônes et il ya
quand même 20 à 25% de la population qui
sont dans ce cas d'accord qui ont aussi
énormément moins de nuances ceux qui ont
compté plus de 50 il ya un souci ça ne
va pas plus de 50
pour informations intéressant n'est-ce
pas ah ouais ouais et bien maintenant
qu'on a fait ce petit test et conseils
que tes yeux fonctionne on va pouvoir
leur faire faire des expériences très
intéressante sur la couleur la réception
la perception les émotions le principe
de la négativité savoir cette formidable
complet rester après la pub
il existe beaucoup de moyens permettant
de constater nos différences internes de
perception ou d'interprétation de
couleur dans le 2ème matière grise de la
saison une nous avions d'ailleurs
constaté ce genre de particularités avec
la robe bleue ou la basket aux roses il
a été démontré entre autres dans une
étude publiée dans biology of sex
différence que les femmes perçoivent
plus de couleurs que les hommes en fait
elles perçoivent plus des nuances
identifie très vite un changement de
teinte une autre étude de john carver
avance l'hypothèse que les femmes
prêterait aussi plus d'attention que les
hommes aux couleurs enfin ces mêmes
études ont démontré que les hommes
percevait mieux les mouvements certains
avancent donc l'hypothèse que ces
particularités et daterait de nos
ancêtres chasseurs cueilleurs mais rien
ne vient à ce jour confirmé
scientifiquement cette idée maintenant
c'est sans peine et dans un arc en ciel
de joie que je vous annonce le sponsor
du jour moi même salut c'est fabien en
fait je suis désolé de vous le dire mais
il y aura pas de sponsor narnia cette
fois c'est la première fois que ça
arrive dans l'histoire de matière grise
mais là je peux pas en fait le truc
c'est qu'on a un petit problème avec les
rucks vidéo qu'on avait déjà tourné un
et c'est dommage parce qu'on avait fait
un petit scénario incroyable avec loïc
on était parti filmer à londres et en os
de big ben on avait prévu un sosie de
charles comme ce qui était en train de
birmans magazine vous savez curieuse et
ça ça devait vous rappeler que prochain
numéro allez sortir que le sommaire
était dingue excès si vous arrêtez pas
bonne et c'était peut-être que le moment
surtout durant le livre dans le monde
entier et qu'on mettrait un lien dans la
distribution enfin tout le truc mais de
là on faisait un lien de dingue parce
que tu as sherlock ce qui se retourne
face caméra et qui disait
il à bâle charlot qu'il montre est mon
dernier livre il la prochaine l'écran
tout prêts tout près de l'écran tu
voyais plus que les livres et autres
gros des hommes quand se retrouver dans
les rues de new york alors il y avait il
ya pas trop de liens avec new york mais
c'est un peu style est quand même new
york et là tu as un mec qui danse dans
la rue il allait claquer des doigts et
au moment précis où traite des doigts et
baby by me faisait me donne york il
envoyer mon livre mon nouveau livre sur
les écrans de times square et là
j'arrive est juste en dessous de l'écran
pour vous expliquer qu'après des années
avoir travaillé sur la mémoire je devais
enfin d'écrire un livre complet sur le
sujet à 360 degrés un livre qui parle
aussi d'un de fonctionnement précis et
médical du cerveau des troubles du
système d'amélioration des techniques
pour tout mémoriser dans son quotidien
et ses et à paresser sur l'écran une
grosse phrase était en gros y'a marqué
10 buts ont tous dû gueuler ils devront
surtout les chipeaux qt est au mieux
dans le studio d'ailleurs dans la vidéo
sorti juste avant ce matière grise je
parlais mémoire dans une vidéo bien fait
de 35 minutes avec un invité mais voilà
il n'y aura pas tout ça parce qu'on a
perdu et rush du coup il n'y aura pas de
sponsor désolé
[Musique]
sûrement ma partie préférée de cette
vidéo vous allez bien sûr pouvoir le
faire en même temps que nous c'est
presque magique à vivre nous allons
utiliser la persistance rétinienne les
cellules de la rétine garde en mémoire
une image pendant environ un dixième de
seconde c'est ce qui fait par exemple
que nous avons l'illusion de voir un
mouvement fluide dans un film alors
qu'il n'y a que 24 images par seconde
sur l'écran en tout cas la rétine garde
les images et ne peut pas distinguer les
deux images différentes les thaumatrope
2826 faisait appel à ce principe mais on
peut aussi se servir de la persistance
rétinienne pour transformer du noir et
blanc en couleurs
mates je vais te présenter un illustre
personnage à qui fait partie de ta
famille il me semble oui oui de maths se
la pète
avait avec cette photo là on va essayer
de voir comment fonctionne le principe
de la persistance rétinienne convient de
voir sur le trauma trope mais à
l'échelle de la luminosité l'effet
négatif des choses je vais te confier
l'ipad en quelques secondes on va voir
la photo en négatif tu vas te la place
est vraiment proche de tes yeux un ok
pour couvrir un maximum de temps champ
de vision et tu va regarder à peu près
là là ce point dans le coup me paraît
très bien tu vas garder cette position
durant une minute une minute trente une
minute trente commencé on se rassure et
après tu switch sera sur la photo en
noir et blanc pour essayer de voir si la
couleur pour apparaître dessus d'accord
couleurs qui viendra de ton
développement interne du négatif alors
ce que tu vas voir le plus et n'hésite
pas à garder l'attention même si tu vois
rien de départ parce que ça va se
développer après ce sera plus le bleu
qui a ici toutes les zones bleues roses
qui vont apparaître cc
le pardessus risque de pas très bien
fonctionné ok elle vous prêts banco
comme on dit allons-y
parfait bien oui tu as tu peux bien là
mais rochelle comme ça
mais bien pour regarder vos j'ai
l'impression
tu peux faire le switch alors a
effectivement effectivement on est sur
du bleu ici le rouge du col donc toi tu
as réussi à voir quand même sur cette
photo en noir et blanc un bleu pas aussi
clair bien sûr un c est un petit peu de
rouge deux cols c'est ça ok scarlett est
peut-être intéressant et si tu veux le
refaire chez toi avec tes amis par
exemple pour un dîner voilà c'est pour
vraiment le genre d'activités jeune
femme vient manger à la maison c'est sûr
sûr sûr un visage sur un visa la corne
que tu joues tu fais une partie en noir
et blanc vous pouvez le faire chez vous
une partie que vous passez sous
photoshop ou sous un logiciel que vous
mettez en négatif de la même dimension
évidemment et sur les visages ça marche
quand même pas mal la leçon que nous a
un peu pourri on voulait faire la blague
mais ça fonctionne un peu moins par
contre c'est un peu fou de se dire ok ce
rouge que tu as vu la whey s'est
transformé en bleu une fois qu'ils
appliquent sur du noir et blanc ouais
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai le
système de fonctionnement c'est vraiment
ce qui se passe dans un endroit on va
développer des pellicules c'est à dire
que ton cerveau
c'est très connu retourne les images
dans sa tête mais il inverse si les
images à l'encodage sur la persistance
rétinienne ce qui fait que ce que tu
viens de voir si tu le plaquent ailleurs
tu vas le voir dans son spectre inverse
c'est pour ça que quand tu regardes le
soleil ou la lumière pendant longtemps
si on regarde la province tu vois une
tache noire en fait c'est juste parce
que tu as regardé du blanc qui se
transforma en noir mais si demain tu
regardes une lumière bleue durant
longtemps tu verras du rouge ensuite à
la place de cette lumière bleue d'accord
là comment fonctionne ton imac d'accord
intéressant l'intéressant beau vous
donner ce que vous écoutez ce qui est
sûrement l étude nom d'un chien à les
expériences suivant exactement
pour le mouvement c'est la persistance
positive qui rentrent en jeu pour le
test que nous venons de faire nous avons
fait appel à la persistance négative qui
durent plus longtemps de la positive
l'exposition longue à une source
lumineuse va abîmer les bâtonnets la
rétine on va donc garder une image
sombre en négatif de la source lumineuse
comme lorsque l'on regarde le soleil
trop longtemps ou qu'on se lâche
cependant une photo mais pour être
complet avec vous sachez que certaines
personnes contestent cette hypothèse par
exemple les chercheurs américains joseph
et barbara anderson dans tous les cas je
trouve magique notre capacité à absorber
le négatif d'une image pour ensuite
appliquer la couleur sur du noir et
blanc ça c'est un peu fou
[Musique]
il est temps maintenant de s'amuser avec
les couleurs pour un grand c'est à vous
on revient sur des tests plus classiques
les tests que vous allez pouvoir faire
vous aussi en même temps on va commencer
par le test de ce troupeau connais-tu ce
stand ce test décidément je ne vois pas
du tout de quoi tu
mets qui venait de bâle ok tu connais
balle oui c'est ce trou de balle
chacun son humour en fin de journée je
te laisse cette petite fille et je vais
te de me demander de me lire le plus
vite possible les mots que tu vois s'il
te plaît les mots les mots absolument
hockey jaune noir violet orange bleu
vert bleu rouge jaune ça c'est parfait
je te demandais maintenant s'il te plaît
de me lire le plus vite possible les
couleurs que tu vois on va enchaîner
deux fiches d'affilée ac non pas les
mots mais les couleurs le plus vite
possible c'est ça qui est important ok
c'est parti vert jaune rouge noir vert
bleu rouge rose vert vert rouge vert
bleu jaune rose vert bleu rouge
ah c'est pas mal
bravo c'était peut-être pas le plus
rapide mais évidemment c'était plus long
que ton premier coup le test de ce
troupes il montre sa une fois que tu
connais le langage c'est très très dur
en fait de simples de se détacher la
lecture de mots on peut pas te faire
voir un mot et te dire ne le lis pas tu
vois si tu sais le lire tu le lis
instantanément c'est un mode automatique
du cerveau et du coup c'est assez
marrant de voir dans l'espèce de ses
troupes qu'il le démontre que le
l'impact de la couleur en fait il est
quand même parasité par l'environnement
en gros ce que ça démontre c'est surtout
un truc marrant pour pour produire
vasily les couleurs l'acte que les
couleurs maintenant je cherche toujours
à revenir dessus en permanence pourquoi
parce que les couleurs on pense qu'elles
sont nickel sont figés qui pensent que
le vr6 du verre en fait le vert c'est
plein de choses et des fois même le
verre c'est pas du verre et ton cerveau
te dis mon petit bonhomme ça c'est du
vert or c'est la perception et pour
quelqu'un qui connaît le cinéma comme
toi on essaye monsieur tu connais la
balance des blancs tu connais ce genre
de choses l'étalonnage qui nous permet
de transformer les couleurs nous faire
croire une un peu une nouvelle
colorimétrie le ton cerveau c'est le
plus grand coloriste il le fait en
permanence mais tu en as vraiment pas
conscience donc je peux te le prouver
par exemple avec à ça doit cesser pièces
d'échecs
sont toutes de la même couleur comme tu
peux le constater ce sont des pièces
noires ouais sont toutes les couleurs ce
sont des pièces blanches là où ton
servante hautement c'est qu' il n'y a
que des pièces de la même couleur en
haut comme en bas d'accord donc cette
pièce est cette pièce est exactement la
même couleur ah ouais est-ce que tu
l'acceptent ou est-ce que tu arrives à
le voir deux choses différentes je peux
l'accepter aussi tu peux ne pas
l'accepter me traiter de menteur vous
êtes un menteur en anglais
en vrai pour moi même en concentrant sur
les 2 c je ne parviens pas à voir
les mêmes couleurs au col j'ai voulu te
démontrer cette partie en préparant la
vidéo je tombais sur plein de choses que
je connaissais des derniers des choses
comme ça quand je suis tombé là dessus
dans une de mes recherches je dis bien
en live sans tromper donc j'ai découpé
pour pouvoir vérifier que cette pièce là
quand je la descend ici il n'ya pas de
bien vraiment aucun souci de l'un à
l'autre et alors le roi c'est assez
drôle parce qu'il a quand même de gros
truc blanc comme ça toi qui es
complètement éclaté tu dis ça ne
marchera jamais eh bien si ça fonctionne
et en plus cette année puisque début tu
grande dans le nord at il dit ça va pas
impressionner et ça fonctionne très bien
mais d'accord des deux côtés et
évidemment je vais l'accepter et
n'acceptera jamais en fait et
d'ailleurs il ya un scientifique qui
s'appelle akiyoshi kitaoka facile à
retenir si j'aurais plus quoi tu vois il
a créé une illusion qui s'appelle les
fraises rouge hockey sont celles ci
d'accord quand tu prends la pipette sous
photoshop c'est pour ça que c'est une
oeuvre d'art tu t'aperçois que c'est
vraiment du rouge est en fait en mettant
tout cet environnement bleus comme ça à
la place du blanc il réussit en fait à
de brainfuck à te faire croire que c'est
pas du rouge parce que c'est un cerveau
encore une fois qu'il refait sa balance
et et ses fraises la ses fraises rouge à
fond bleu si tu l'aimés sous un ciel
bleu ça va encore faire plus ressortir
le bleu tu verras encore plus le reste
gris si on le mettait sous une lumière
tenten par exemple aurait pour pouvoir
d'atténuer le bleu et tuent les vers est
plus rouge en fait tout dépend de ton
environnement lumineux pour que ton
cerveau réinterprète les couleurs en
permanence et la balance des blancs
garman ans donc ce que tu crois être les
couleurs que tu vois ça n'existe pas la
perception des couleurs et la réception
des couleurs sont tellement intime
son trafic est en permanence de quoi
non ya pas de rouge justement
oui c'est ça c'est ça alors là il s'est
passé quand même quelque chose
d'exceptionnel vous ne l'avez pas eu il
ya eu un petit bois peut-être que vous
avez entendu un extrait voici ce qu'il
vient de se passer j'ai écrit ces
épisodes - ya trois mois tu vois avant
qu'on tourne et je me suis fait brain
plus que brain garde toi tu vois
quelques nuances de rouge ou pas quand
même ben franchement je pense après je
ne sais pas si c'est parce que tu me l'a
expliqué d'une certaine manière mais il
me semble que la danse et au delà sur la
sur la fraise je pense voir un peu de
rouge moi plus je le regarde plus voit
du rouge vin personnellement et en fait
la réalité qui viennent nous rattraper
c'est quand même génial quand il fait
une vidéo sur la perception des couleurs
c'est qu'il n'y a pas une seule goutte
de rouge à des pipettes au contraire de
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure déjà ne
me croyez jamais vérifier les infos mais
il n'y a pas une seule goutte de rouge
et il n'y a pas un seul pixel drôle
c'est que du gris mais c'est hallucinant
parce que même moi je vais me faire
avoir par le propre truc
alors par contre ce que je vous ai dit
par rapport au fait que du ciel bleu et
du tungstène en réalité il ya une
explication très logique à ça et je
raccordé à une petite bêtise que a
expliqué ce même chercheur et vous en
parle tout de suite
les couleurs sont donc un mélange de
données qui rentre dans l'oeil et une
interprétation ensuite du cerveau cours
le psychologue expérimental akiyoshi
kitaoka à créer l'illusion des fraises
il explique que si vous marchez dehors
sous un ciel bleu le bleu en un sens
contamine de sa couleur tout ce que vous
voyez mais saviez vous que les couleurs
avait un réel impact sur nos émotions et
nos capacités on va voir ça tout de
suite
[Musique]
depuis des années la science s'intéresse
à l'impact des couleurs sur notre
cerveau est ce qu'elles influencent
notre jugement notre motivation nos
émotions c'est ce qu'on appelle la
psychologie de la couleur ce que l'on
appelle la psychologie de la couleur
intéressent à la fois les scientifiques
est le monde de la publicité de l'art et
de la communication mais il reste
compliqué d'être précis sur l'impact des
couleurs sur nos émotions car il dépend
entre autres de la culture de l'époque
et du lieu où vit la personne la science
de l' influence de la couleur aurait
plus de deux siècles d'existence
généralement on s'accorde à dire que son
point de départ et lorsque le
naturaliste johann wolfgang von goethe
publie ses travaux en psychologie des
couleurs il serait compliqué de tester
réellement l'impact des couleurs sur
matt mais nous allons faire un test
inversée
parlons maintenant map du pouvoir des
couleurs sur nos émotions c'est que les
couleurs du coup sont énormément utilisé
par les marques ouais je t'ai mis plein
de marques connues comme ça ne peut pas
me faire attaquer donc quand je mets des
marques ici et dans quelques secondes je
vais te donner des des caractéristiques
un peu émotionnel et je vais te demander
de me trilles et des petits paquets
corps il restera des cartes à la fin des
petits paquets de cartes qui selon toi
correspondre un petit peu à cette
tonalité lorsqu'il ses tonalités
émotionnel je les ai pas choisis parce
que je savais que tel logo tel logo
l'avait fait exprès j'ai pris juste au
contraire des rapports psychologiques
i10 telle couleur véhicules telle
émotion et on va voir si c'est un match
et si ça a été un peu réfléchi en amont
par les publicités comme ça si ça marche
pas ce sera pas moi ce sera bien les
publicitaires qui ont pas votre chaise
ok ok ok moi je m'en sors vous faites
moi je vois c'est les petites astuces
est ce que vous êtes prêt vous ferez vos
petits tas sur le côté en fait le petit
je fais ma pote on va faire s'il vous
plaît confiance
tranquillité conscience tranquille et
d'un clan tranquillité confiance
tranquillité mais vrai que tu me tues
pour art changer tes choix de petits tas
tout à l'heure au pied par hockey
confiance tranquillité twitter non je ne
suis pas du tout confiance tranquillité
c'est pas mal ça c'est plus pour ce que
ça m'inspire ce qui se cache derrière la
marque ambitions audace autorités
ambitions audace autorités ambitions
audace autorités ambitions das autorité
va quand même encore une fois on ne
focalise pas que sur la marque mais
aussi quand t'as pas trop d'idées tu
peux vous dire puisque le cette couleur
elle m'inspire guère ont l'audace par
exemple audace autorités ce serait
quelques couleurs pour toi audace
autorités je dirais wep ou vers le vert
le vert le rouge plus tôt j'ai
l'impression alors on peut regarder un
petit peu ce qui est rouge tu as quand
même en rouge quelque chose qui
s'appelle tnt ouais tu allais gotha
youtube la coca cola et nintendo moi je
mettrais coca cola mois déjà moi je
trouve que en
si si le rouge est vraiment ambitions
audace on n'a pas autorité mois on a de
l'ambition audace ouais ouais ouais
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que ça t'inspire là
tous ces roses la leur hausse a un côté
un peu d'où un peu soft ouais donc c'est
ça va à contresens de l'autre de
l'autorité en fait je sais pas si ça a
un sens
mais c'est intéressant le rose je te le
dire c'est jeunesse douceur ludique
d'innocence d'accord donc jeunesse
douceur en lalla
ludique peut-être calipage innocence de
sf paris tupperware pourquoi pas mais en
tout cas si eux ils ont réfléchi à ça je
trouve que ça marche bien avec larmes à
fait réussi bien joué fraîcheur nature
slash optimisme à les 1000 cas parce que
je vois une vache dans un prêt tout
simplement slash nature c'était quoi les
le premier clash optimisme optimisme ça
n'a pas vraiment de sens mais j'ai pas
le bleu me convaincre le maître dans
cette case là je sais pas pourquoi mais
si je te dis énergie bonheur optimisme
bonheur les lego ça rappelle quand tu
étais quand on était gamins bonheur
boubaiou tubes mais ça c'est parce que
voilà
c'est le côté bonheur le côté heureux
quoi nintendo bonheur optimisme
oui oui oui oui oui bah alors énergie on
est sur du on est sur du du monster
forcément si je te dis authenticité
calme relaxation plaisir allez un petit
nespresso
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal alors ça
montre que c'est pas si instantanée que
ça parce que ça correspond pas forcément
à tous mes codes couleurs maintenant on
va on va comparer ce que tu as fait mais
surtout je vais te dire quels sont les
les vraies émotions véhiculées par les
couleurs et ce qu'on cherchait
réellement à faire des marques en fait
en réalité ok productivité ou apaisement
ou tranquillité ou confiance c'est le
bleu d'accord c'est pour ça qu'en
réalité facebook s'est mis en bleu pour
l'apaisement la tranquillité et c'est
que paypal s'est mis en bleu pour la
confiance que hp 6000 en bleu pour la
tranquillité du caire reuters émis en
bleu on sait pas tellement
ce soit pour la tranquillité ou pour la
productivité
le rouge c'est bien l'ambition l'audace
l'énergie de l'autorité alors des fois
on trouve des objectifs sur plusieurs
couleurs mais en tout cas antilles c'est
d'une manière certaine que c'est pour ça
que nintendo et coca et qu'on en trouve
aussi dans la nasa ce sondage coupe le
bleu de la nasa il est vraiment pour le
ciel le rouge c'est vraiment pour
ambition audace et c'est ce qu'on fait
au cas aussi et nintendo portia énergie
toujours avec aussi le côté bonheur
optimisme c'est plutôt le jaune c'est
plutôt le jaune or quand on va retrouver
du coût d'un mcdo qu'est ce qu'on a on a
élégance royauté pouvoir et luxe il n'y
a pas trop parlé de ça mais c'est le
viol est un c'est vraiment la couleur du
violet c'est pour ça que ces deux là
d'ailleurs ces mamans en fait au final
c'est vraiment il ya quelque chose de
l'ordre du classe mais un peu royal quoi
pour les marques très
luxueuse on va plutôt chercher des
choses dans le marron tu vois comme
nespresso mnm ce dont on sait qu'ils ont
pris pour le chocolat mais n'empêche que
du coup ça répond à ça ou une icône où
ils ont quand même leur fiabilité dans
le jaune et leur énergie ils ont gardé
quand même une grande part de noir pour
le côté d'authenticité quand même
d'accord elle cotait marron du coup tu
le retrouves aussi des sur louis vuitton
qu'est ce qui nous manque il nous manque
d'ambition de nouveaux enthousiasme et
confiance et c'est vraiment l'un 10 de
confiance en réalité orange orange
orange orange orange ah ouais d'accord
et en communication c'est vraiment la
couleur de la communication le orange et
tu t'aperçois que toutes les marques qui
veulent inspirer confiance en fait elle
utilise le orange parce que c'est le
moins chargée émotionnellement
donc ça évite de véhiculer des choses
agressif comme le rouge ou trop
tranquille trop productives comme le
bleu ou des trucs dehors au précieux
comme le viol etc ça va être la couleur
un peu neutre en fait marketing
émotionnel coop d'accord le rose on l'a
vu jeunesse douceur ludique innocence et
puis je te le dis tout à leur
authenticité fiabilité calme relaxation
pour eau pour le marron voilà très bien
donc tu vois la part des marques quand
même réfléchissent toit après suivant
l'image que tu as de la marque tu vas
tribunes ça dans un sens ou dans un
autre mais c'est intéressant une fois qu
on les regroupe de se dire et c'est pas
si déconnant de trouver ces mêmes
couleurs ensemble ces mêmes couleurs
ensemble on a vraiment pris les marques
au hasard c'est à dire la personne qui
les a préparés savais pas ce que
j'allais en faire après d'accord tu vois
les marques sont prises au hasard et tu
dis ben ouais ça marche en fait tnt
orange arte c'est le même domaine ils
sont tous orange eux ils vendent du
service
qui veulent un peu précieux ils sont
tous dans du violet ils sont tous dans
le digital avec un des données
sécurisées sur toi il te met un truc de
productivité de tranquillité eu complot
des trucs familiaux mais en même temps
ambitieux quoi tu vois vidéo on peut
devenir le tube heures on peut trouver
plein de contenus légaux tu construis
des choses mcdo c'est un truc familial
mais qui est rapide tu vois qui sert
vite etc on retrouve tous les
combinaisons de rouge et jaune donc
consciemment ou inconsciemment ou même
peut-être même chose deux ans
consciemment ou inconsciemment on
retrouve toujours le même couleur quand
des émotions veulettes véhicules et
accor voilà intéressant voilà qui
permettra de penser à terminer de
différent bien sûr très importants en
europe 1de retombe mur et je vais
peut-être le médecin en orange histoire
d'être un petit peu plus petit peu plus
notre un petit peu plus confortant c'est
ça oui c'est vrai ça vous a plu et ben
c'était très intéressant vous mettrez 5
étoiles bien sûr bien sûr du sétois les
leçons de quelle couleur sur les
affiches bleues sur dépend des cas les
miennes seront bleus semblent la
tranquillité la fiabilité à verdille
éviter voilà tout ce que tu m'inspires
famille merci beaucoup merci à sa merci
d'avoir joué le jeu de ces quatre
expériences très cool
pour aller plus loin sur la psychologie
des couleurs je vous recommande vivement
la vidéo tedx de jean-gabriel causse
film en 2015 vous comprenez mieux
maintenant pourquoi certaines marques
comme mcdonald's décide un jour de
changer la couleur majeur de leur marque
c'est par hasard merci à tous les
participants à toute l'équipe à charles
oxman et dated à la production à loïc à
la réal avec toute l'équipe est bien sûr
amat n'hésitez pas à découvrir ces
vidéos c'est un régal le lien est dans
la description le prochain épisode de
matière grise sera publiée le mois
prochain et il parlera de la
manipulation mentale vous pouvez vous
abonner gratuitement à cette chaîne
c'est pas de la manipulation c'est si
cette série vous plaît vous avez
également les 15 épisodes précédents de
matière grise dans la description
alors notre pensée est elle vraiment un
manipulable les couleurs sont elles le
seul facteur qui peut nous influencer
vous saurez tout cela bien plus dans les
prochains épisodes de matière grise à
très bientôt ciao
[Musique]